Chris curry from Anchorage in Alaska
wants to know whether regular people by
which he means I think people are not
scientifically trained can still
contribute to scientific understanding
in a way that I suppose he feels that
they could in the past before everything
became so technical I think it's uh on
the one hand not possible to think in a
productive or an effective way about
science without studying without
mastering a subject I mean any what we
do indeed most of the science that goes
on is understandable by and could be
pursued I think by an ordinary by any
ordinary person there's nothing so
profound that it requires any very rare
aptitude to grasp and to do so the
answer is on the one hand of that it
that are what the questioner refers to
is an ordinary person would have to be
willing to invest to learn and to
understand but at the same time any
ordinary person would be capable of
doing it I would add to that that I
think it's terribly important for all
ordinary people to learn about and
understand chemistry and the particular
types of thing we and others do as I
have said to you earlier on there's
really nothing more valuable to the life
of any person than to have some
conception
the chemical basis for all of what goes
on around us
you